[OLD COMPUTER NOISES]
Hello.
I'm Timothy Jordan.
And this is your update about
the coolest developer news
from Google in the last week.
Now, studies have shown that
an increase in performance
leads to happier,
more-engaged users, which
is why you should check out this
post on the new APIs in Chrome
to help you improve
scroll performance.
Frameworks like Ruby
on Rails and Sinatra
make it easy for developers to
rapidly build web applications
and APIs for the cloud.
And App Engine provides
an easy-to-use platform
for developers to build, deploy,
and manage and automatically
scale services on Google's
infrastructure, which
is why we're excited that Ruby
Runtime on Google App Engine
is going beta.
For more details and links
to the Getting Started Guide,
samples, and interactive
tutorials, check out the post.
And that's it.
It's light today
because everybody
is, mmm, focused on
Google I/O next week.
[CHEERING]
Seriously, it's going
to be a lot of fun.
Oh, and there won't be a TL;DR
next week because the "Dev
Show" team will be on the ground
at I/O getting your questions
answered.
Make sure to use the
hashtag #askdevshow.
And don't forget to like,
subscribe, and share.
I'm Timothy Jordan.
And I'll see you next time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
What are you still doing here?
The video's over, and
Google I/O is next week.
Let's get to work.
[MUSIC PLAYING]